[Musik]
mit gottes
zwei jahren zu tag herrschaft ist
symbolischen start ist die groß
abschlussprüfung für die junge
diplomaten
[Musik]
da passiert was
erste effekte auf deutsche
diplomatie ist in der schweiz nicht
besonders beliebt man kennt bös wenn das
ist vielleicht schon auf sie zählen wir
für die nächsten jahrzehnte
[Musik]
samira will diplomatin warten
sie macht die zwei jahre gültig ob im
eidgenössische departement für
auswärtige angelegenheiten
zusammen mit ihrem mann ist sie fügt
aber gabriel
die mutter und ihre geschwister mit zum
8 wahrscheinlich von fünf junge leute
auf ihrem wagen diplomatie begleitet
wartet sie zweieinhalb monate ist sie
jetzt schon der diplomatenausbildung vom
bund im buch diplomatisch
ok
dominante edgar sind sie zwei jahre
verortet und damit genauso lang auf
honig
sie musste von afrika einzig die zwei
kennen gelernt
jüdischer sport
[Musik]
ich glaube es gibt nichts wichtigeres
familie extrem stark war das ist sondern
zur familie graf riesig sie hat sonne
hätte hauptversion vertrautem einem
lager sehr dass sie aber das cassis owb
und dass das für mich war das okay ist
unser dankeschön grund sagt diplomat
vorteil ich verursache größte position
haut und da muss man kompromisse machen
und diese position gedachte mit sauberen
sprachen haben je nach situation aber du
hast gesagt haben die auch personen sie
ihre situation kriegen hatte hintergrund
hat samira hätte sein sicherung rolle
spielt dass so viele möglichkeiten von
der behinderung die verschiedenen
kulturen und länder das interessiert zu
mir
sie diente nationale beziehungen
studiert und nach einer theorie
organisation für friedenspolitik
schaffen gut die basis für die
diplomatische wird sicher schwierig aber
irgendwie das heißt es nerven mit
zukünftige partner und zukünftigen
familie
[Musik]
die größte fortschritt zwischen los wird
sie 1 1 gleich gewinn gleichgewicht zu
finden mit der begleitperson die
karriere der begleitpersonen irgendwie
zu harmonisieren mit deiner karriere
sondern alle vier jahre muss einfach weg
und den wie die karriere verdiente
person unterbrochen das ist ein ganz
großer erforderlich ich finde man spürt
das gewicht da nichts sagen das gut
verteilt autobauer jonas berliner macht
diplomat war dass ich mir nur eine große
freunde fürs leben
bevor sie ihre partnerin kathrin und
fordert tochter seines teams an dreht
sich weg der berufswahl von jonas der
physiker und die klassischen sich aber
also ja ich habe jetzt auch im quartett
gegründet
drei alle gitarristen als bern so meine
kulturelle inspiration sozusagen die
landschaft das ich führe zukünftig
diplomaten aus frau möglich
heimatverbundenheit und die zukunft das
eigentlich egal ob die werte im regen
etwas wie zwei helle sehen die spanische
botschaft war heute guten morgen
wow das klingt ja unglaublich ja super
ja auf jeden fall also ich wäre sehr
interessiert ok super ist es sehr vielen
dank für ihren anruf und ich bin
wirklich ganz erfreut
wow kraus anrufe bekommt von der
sekretärin der spanischen botschaft
darin genau hier in bern
und ja sie hat für mich gehört und
wollte jetzt fragen ob ich für events
bei ihnen spanische musik spielen könnte
ja das ist doch ideal also das passiert
noch keine ahnung das ist toll
[Musik]
naja
wir haben wirklich gut wenn wir dies
natürlich
ja jetzt ist es wird schon bald mit der
heime für die junge familie sie zu der
diplomat ausbildung gehört der
praktische teil unserer botschaft der
jonas reißt den sv menne tragen
meine es ist extrem wichtig das ist für
sie gut ist und er hat es dann nicht so
starke verantwortlich unzählige dann
sind aber gleichzeitig ist wirklich
schwierig im voraus gesehen was es
bedeutet in einer intellektuellen
verständnis aber einfach rein emotional
wie das tatsächlich da ist habe ich
nicht voraussagen
wenn die jonas mit ihrer ausbildung
fertig ist virtuell vier jahre
miteinander land schaffen sagt ein
rotationsprinzip wird zyklen zum
lebensstil tendenz würden kpn schädiger
und meine erfahrung zeigt dass sie hin
und wieder viele mehr verbucht sagt
lohse
war
[Musik]
oliver knoll ca und hört wieder
beruhigen und das friedlich ist normal
wirkliche starke verein blick also hier
gesagt man noch großes feld und das
sitzt fast abgeschlossen
also es ist unglaublich wie schnell das
ist geld
tv tipp vom klimawandel ist definitiv da
ist was maschine bringt und jonas iwak
diplomatie ungewöhnlich
naturwissenschaftler und vielleicht bald
diplomat
[Musik]
die premiere ein us-präsident empfängt
einen schweizer bundespräsidentin im
weißen haus zu einem gespräch über
freihandel und diplomatie
maurer trifft dort ist das ein
diplomatische große volk der bundesrat
im jahr zu gast und 10 360 diplomatinnen
und diplomaten schafft genau für das die
trasse von der schweizer die globale
politik ein wichtige rolle spiele und
wirtschaft kultur und frieden schweizer
war in zukunft im ausland gehört werden
diplomatische nachwuchs ist also nötig
es ist nicht nur einfach ein schönes
politisches dass man nach offiziellem
erhält diplomaten es ist eine
überlebensfrage tweets dass mir über das
netz sind
[Musik]
wieso habe ich die nicht und keine sein
jean baptiste scheine von einer weniger
wofür die diplomatisch muss politik muss
gewählt worden ist
der entwurf diplomatisch von ihnen stark
mit nigeria verknüpft ich bin da und das
war meine erste erfahrung beim bund bei
beim eda auch dass das praktikum wo ich
vielleicht die idee gehabt ja vielleicht
diploma sie genau das ist das
abschiedsfest von von botschafter also
er hat mich sehr motiviert das einmal zu
probieren hat mich ihr engagement
tiefster dass das musst du hin einmal
probieren
das ist das ist wirklich sehr spannend
da musst du uns das machen
justine der shortlist für die york
sondern bleibt sie wort redet in
ostafrika als entwicklungshilfe schockt
afrika
[Musik]
das hat für das abt ist reise viel
tamtam objektiv beraten endlich
justieren
klasse kommt aus aller welt
viele freiheiten und das trotz der
politisch schwierige situation
[Musik]
gerade wenn wir angekommen sind
1990 hat einen kriegen gefangen sind
rebellen aus dem norden gekommen und
dann plötzlich hat hat frankreich
gruppen nacheinander geschickt und die
regierung zu unterstützen und als king
du fandest das voll cool oder wir haben
das nicht realisiert das ist eigentlich
ein krieg gab fast nur landung was ein
krieg ist oder was passiert
ich erinnere mich ich glaube das war ein
erster august oder und ich weihnachten
ein fest organisiert natürlich mit der
dena fleisch und raclette das noch immer
ist und mein bruder und ich mussten uns
so an kleidern und den leuten kleine
schock ist einmal die an kann das habe
ich ihm mit helfern die die
schweizerische gemeinschaft die micky
galli und man wurde noch nicht war ein
so lächerlichen gekleidet und wir müssen
diese des hitzeschocks zu erteilen
also damals schon nämlich ein schweizer
vertretung mit jahre alt gemacht
[Musik]
amor frankfurter diplomat ausbildet gott
sie verschiedene kurs und diplomatische
handwerk dazu gehöre die richtige
umgangsformen generieren lerntyp
punktlos
jean baptiste das credo von berg ist
nobel hotel etikett und protokolle das
heißt wie man sich in einen
diplomatischen umfeld bedient also wie
man ja eigentlich
[Musik]
nein lautete schon alle weg zum vortag
entschuldigung
ein anderer diplomat des dossiers sind
pünktlich um etikette kurz nicht ganz
unwichtig jean baptiste ganze spezielle
klaric für sie nie versperrt
[Musik]
und zwar fast glücklich heute morgen
aber ich habe auf dem weg ein eine
fernsehcrew getroffen hat mich ein
bisschen verspätet
der witz nach den ohne gott los und es
ist klar welches thema hat gross
leiterin gerade am anfang bringt
[Musik]
pünktlichkeit wir haben das gestern
nachmittag im zusammenhang mit den
einladungskarten bereits angeschaut
einladung zum essen maximal 15 minuten
später als die angegebene zeit in west-
europäischen kontext gott jetzt gehen
wir das große thema der begrüßung und
man denkt das ist ein normaler handys
lage ist es aber nicht und da kommen wir
eben auch auf den körper aus druckerei
auf die körper verhelfen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
also wenn ich jetzt zu ihm gehe und ich
begrüße ihn wird meine handfläche nach
oben
dann gebe ich bereits bekannt wer jetzt
hier zu sagen hat und das ist der
insofern auch spannend anzuschauen dass
er putin obwohl er für sich nicht größer
ist es schafft auch bei märklin oder
zuschauen also eher begrüßt mich jetzt
dominant ja so was ich mache ist einen
kleinen schritt nach rechts so trotz
dann dreht sich die hand automatisch
relative partie kontrolle diese nur
resources intercity tief heraus wir
bieten keine rauchpausen schminkt und
andere pausen zu machen könnt ihr
nachher wir gehen alle miteinander und
das mittagessen die masse warte die der
diplomatie immer wichtige themen
besprochen
die richtige tischmanieren da so sieht
das einfach immer wieder passiert im
laufe der jahre
[Musik]
wenn ich euch mal ein guten appetit
wenn das kein prozess ja wir können wir
mit dem static zusammen leider passiert
das nie draußen etwas zeit wie salate
bekommen
[Musik]
man darf
salat nicht schneiden ich glaube das
macht man nicht
diesmal in der vielleicht mit brot
jena du bist ja ohne messe normalerweise
salat einfach mit mit gabel und
eventuell brot so stimmt das nicht
gemacht
[Musik]
am nachmittag geht's weiter mit
dresscodes mit großer freude und styling
frage wer kennt das auch unser gehirn
ist zuerst mit den visuellen
informationen beschäftigt wenn ich zu
ihnen sagen ich möchte meine
individualität zum ausdruck bringen mit
meinem socken weg wie das in der regel
je höher die grafen geht desto bunter
das konnte ich gesagt zdf an wo man
aufweisen welche chefs dass man im
großen und ganzen eher unter die
kleidung desto niedriger ist die
nachricht oder mäßig oder botschaften
übermitteln
ja er bat farbe gegen rapid mit mit
professionelleren in eleganter und vier
spieler durch monetäre situation so
wichtig ist das problem mit farbe ja ich
mich wegen jetzt tu das nicht
[Musik]
zweiter sind wird christina und
beruflich wichtig sondern ab sofort
einheitlich und wie viel sie den
us-diplomaten die linke
zumindest nicht jetzt genug ist nicht so
also wir damit sieht eigentlich aus
recht gut funktioniert
was will ich hier so die auf dem zettel
so gut aber die nahtstelle zum eu aus
mir das gewünscht hat
die unbedingt das neue maschine mit kino
kommt ist für mich wirklich abschalten
aber gleichzeitig machen kreative bis
machen
im mitgliederverzeichnis ausgleich new
york dpa christina verbraucht die
steirer diplomaten aus politik dieses
land in der ufer trat das passt perfekt
zu der studierte völkerrechtlerin stufe
wird sagt mitarbeiterin sie sogar hinter
kanada und das ist mit ein grund warum
das gut gemacht habe wir sind einfach
sehr schwierig ist wenn man nichts
diplomaten diplomaten ist es schwierig
die sektionschefs beste zu genau das
gibt es immer wieder aber dass menschen
sich sehr sehr gut geht und durch das
kann ich nicht sein und das wird michael
zimmer irgendwas ist auch dieses team
wieder dass das fand ich sehr gespannt
für gong diplomatique braucht viel kraft
und us tour und grad new york gilt
innerhalb von moussa département als
eine von der strengste stationen jean
baptist gespürt wie anspruchsvoll
diplomatenausbildung ist mithilfe wie
politische bricht oder wichtige stadt
organisieren
das gehört zur praktischen ausbildung in
dieser gewöhnlich nicht so viel platz
zeigen
das heißt ich bin doch glücklich dass
ich am büro hier haben konnte und nicht
irgendwo weiterhin bären und das lied
das licht ist übrigens super schön das
ist pflicht
sie ist charmant dann nämlich den lift
tusch parlaments biotech das war 50 50
ja also ich konnte sprachlicher sein um
die treppe dachten übernehmen aber gut
nach so viel hin und zürich vielleicht
habe ich ein angenehmer mythische
wichtigen tag für europa präsentiert
hüttenzauber entwickelte wo zeigt mit
werner länder tweets vertrag öffnen
schon mal dass das an sich ist wahnsinn
nicht viel dass sich die möbel bewege ja
wirklich weiß die kammern sind habe ich
schon kurz gut diese diese diese zwei
jahren die werden wirklich an ein
prozess sein dass ich verstehe also
wieso diese ausbildung sei kein grund
also das diplom hat diesen beruf das
lernt man nicht einfach auf ein youtube
tutorial das ist nimmt zeit und man muss
besser bescheid sein und ein bisschen
geduld
somit ist alles mit buch eine ganz lange
reihe von abkommen viele sind abkommen
im bereich mit hilfe von secure ist aber
dass er da wohl besser gb version der
sonne kann zwar zeigen kann mit diesen
filmen
das kann ich eigentlich ist ja dass das
geht eigentlich so wenn man das feld
doch öffnet hat man gleich die liste vom
alles was unten steht
und ich denke wir hatten auch unser
portal vor ich war effektiv auch sonst
hatten wir da auftrag eine liste zu
machen und ich glaube das wäre ein gutes
angebot für uns gewesen
ich verstehe ja für die botschaft
ergeben dass die mal so etwas auch nicht
sein könnten
[Musik]
ich bin froh es ging gut und die
stimmung ja so sind kollegen oder die
stimmung war gut und es finde ich das
einfach spannend mit mit 34 mit einer
folie berufliche erfahrung da fängst du
in dieses job diplomatie und du musst
einfach alles neu lernen muss
irgendwie es auch eine ergo frage oder
du denkst ich hab doch ich hab doch
schon gerne weiter ich habe studiert und
soundso ich kann schon eigentlich nicht
eigentlich eigentlich muss ich ein
bisschen bescheid sagen muss ich das
muss ich lernen
wirklich bis für dieses land leiste und
dass ich die große chance wurde wowereit
bietet und wo mir spitze liegt rufen und
wir versuchen spitze ried zu erstens
einmal auswählen und ein ausbilder so
dass wir möglicherweise die beste
diplomaten auf der welt ein
[Musik]
mit mühe zwanzigste alexander scheibel
der jüngste diplomat was gut ist die
zürcher mit ihnen ehemaligen wg
mitbewohner unterwegs
[Musik]
unsere arena hat jetzt das netz
harburg
es ist schon schwierig werden ein neues
album und wollte seiner sportart lustige
spiele und es ihnen geht
absolut
ich weiß was da muss man ja wer hat zur
zeit
[Musik]
jetzt noch nicht
eugen römer kannten
die
erfolg ist um alexander wichtig nicht
nur auf dem surfbrett und beruf das ist
ein extrem spannend kurve zusage
abzeichnet hat dass es möglich ist
natürlich dass auch die konferenz ihr
team an experten hier schwarze bis zu
dem als vermieter und jeder wir
verschieden einige zahlen sowie
diskussionen anregen
der diplomat
da gab es schon extrem energiequelle
das stabilste verbirgt sie
das meer
dass sie mir eingebrochen auch das
konzentriert haben schritt für schritt
können und dann sich nie geglückt
wahrscheinlich brauchen
[Musik]
für den 1
diese vertrauen
was war das nun schon her
[Musik]
samira und erdgasindustrie im team und
baltische heimatschutzes berühmte klappt
jetzt in bahn und barcodes weiter auf
kritik
wirklich extrem viel gesprochen und es
[Musik]
war liebe schwitzen ich mir jetzt klar
ist wie zu werk und auch grundzüge das
ist ein roxette organisiert punkt labor
die ganze kultur die ganze möglichst
kultur männer versucht irgendwo zwischen
verschiedenen akteuren mettler und das
ist für mich das wort sache das
schweizer die schon gemacht
[Musik]
da ist
und das floating geklaut
[Musik]
zwischen der wolke plötzlich
[Gelächter]
sie wird vom junger diplomat
[Musik]